[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand on est natif de Verdun comme vous
quand on est français pourquoi on
s'intéresse à l'Afrique
j'ai pas de passer
africain dans ma famille ni d'une
manière ni de l'autre contrairement à la
plupart de de mes collègues qui
travaillons sur l'Afrique mais voilà
c'est vous savez j'ai rencontré à Nancy
qui était la ville de lyaute dans mon
lycée de classe prépa des étudiants
marocains qui étaient là comme une forme
d'héritage et on a sympathisé et
l'histoire a commencé ainsi le tech
était la grande figure de la
colonisation française au Maroc comment
vous expliquer parce que oui à vous mais
il y en a beaucoup qui sont passionnés
par l'Afrique c'est quoi cette passion
française pour l'Afrique c'est dû à quoi
vous savez ça il faut remonter au début
du 19e siècle la France était tournée
vers vers l'Europe elle a fait des
guerres en Europe et puis elle a perdu
ses guerres à partir de 1814 1815
ensuite elle a assisté à la montée de
l'Allemagne la Prusse puis de
l'Allemagne elle s'est tournée à ce
moment-là au cours du 19e siècle vers
l'Afrique et elle a investi toutes ses
forces
qu'elles soient politiques militaires
religieuse intellectuelle une grande
partie de ses forces ont été investies
vers l'Afrique et voilà de siècles après
on en est toujours là alors entre temps
il y a eu le retour de bâton de la
décolonisation et la construction
européenne on le voit bien
qu'effectivement la puissance et la
trait de l'Afrique persiste et penser
que ça grandeur était là il y a une
certaine nostalgie de cette période
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
de la période coloniale je c'est
difficile à dire non parce que la page a
été tournée et au contraire aujourd'hui
on regarde plutôt ça comme un choix qui
était inadapté ou qui nous a attiré
beaucoup de problèmes à la France à la
Cinquième République elle est née dans
un contexte effroyable de ce point de
vue là donc non je crois pas qu'il a
nostalgie mais en revanche il y a une
histoire une histoire alors vous vous
connaissez particulièrement bien parce
que vous y avez vécu vous avez enseigné
l'Afrique du Nord vous êtes passé par
l'Egypte le Maroc la Tunisie il y a
plusieurs Afrique cet Afrique que vous
connaissez très très bien elle est elle
est assez lointaine de l'Afrique
subsaharienne finalement de l'Afrique
noire ah oui
bon il y a même dans l'Afrique du Nord
il y a même l'Égypte ce qui a elle seule
constitue un monde à part à la même la
vallée du Nil à soi seul c'est un monde
et puis il y a l'Afrique du Nord arabo
berbère de la Libye jusqu'au Maroc c'est
une île en arabe d'ailleurs on dit
geserat Al-Maghrib c'est Lille du
Maghreb en arabe
voilà les Berbères l'appellent tamaza
c'est un monde en soi qui est entre la
Méditerranée et le l'océan ça a rien et
elle est coupée du reste alors bien sûr
les liens ont toujours existé et son
permanent avec le sud subsaharien et
avec la l'Europe la Méditerranée mais en
soi ça constitue un monde à part oui et
les relations entre les deux bah elles
ont été marquées par ce qu'on appelle la
traite orientale c'est-à-dire
l'esclavagisme qui était pratiqué par
les Arabes avant justement la traite
occidentale et de cette traite on en
parle quasiment jamais d'ailleurs c'est
comment vous expliquer ça il y avait
cinq grandes routes qui reliaient
l'Afrique subsaharienne à l'Afrique du
Nord et à la Méditerranée
certaines passées effectivement par le
l'Afrique du Nord par le Maroc actuel
l'Algérie la Libye les routes se
terminaient dans les grandes capitales
et puis ensuite les marchandises les
hommes les humains partaient notamment
dans l'Empire ottoman vers Istanbul ou
rester sur place oui ben si vous voulez
c'est une histoire dont on parle peu
parce que la plupart des descendants ont
disparu en réalité la plupart des hommes
ont été castrés et donc contrairement
aux États-Unis il y a pas de descendance
donc il y a pas de il y a pas de peuple
afro descendants de cette histoire en
fait bien sûr certaines personnes ont
fait souche notamment les femmes sont
rentrés je dirais dans la dans la
société mais c'est occulté et notamment
parce que il y a pas de témoin alors
ceux qui en parlent ce sont parfois les
les Africains eux-mêmes notamment les
Sénégalais qui ont écrit là-dessus il y
a des travaux qui ont été fait à sherata
Diop historien sénégalais au Maghreb au
Maroc en Algérie en Tunisie il y a aussi
des historiens qui se sont intéressés
notamment au Maroc mais ça reste quand
même un sujet complexe parce qu'au fond
tout ça a été effacé gommé par la
période coloniale et par les rapports
avec l'Europe et avec la France en
particulier mais néanmoins il y a encore
des subsistances de cette forme de de
esclavagisme même si c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose notamment Mauritanie
où il y a encore ce genre de pratique
qui se qui se qui sont visibles un
Mauritanie dans d'autres pays du Sahel
aussi en Arabie Saoudite c'est ces pays
n'ont jamais rompu officiellement facile
officiellement ils auront pu être
l'esclavagisme notamment sous la
pression des Britanniques ou des
Français ou la pression internationale
si vous voulez le problème c'est que la
colonisation a été le vecteur qui a mis
fin à l'esclavage la colonisation
européenne a mis fin à cela donc ça
n'est pas venu de l'intérieur des
sociétés donc il y a pas eu un mouvement
comme il y a eu en Europe un mouvement
libéral est construit contre
l'esclavagisme au contraire il est
imposé par les Européens de l'extérieur
c'est considéré comme un acte entre
guillemets de violences coloniale donc
vous voyez comment le bien peut
recouvrir le mâle ou l'inverse et du
coup bah à la fin on en parle pas
beaucoup mais bien sûr ça resterait
puissant parce que cette traite elle a
été plus importante que la traite
transatlantique et oui et puis elle a
duré plus de 1000 ans et 12 ou 13
siècles donc c'est quelque chose de
considérable vous êtes d'accord avec
cette phrase des mécères il y a pas un
devoir de mémoire il y a un droit à
l'histoire oui bah l'esclavagisme est un
très bon exemple pour parler de
l'histoire parce qu'il y a plus de
mémoire qui se rappelle avoir eu des
parents des grands-parents des
grands-parents esclaves on le sait mais
l'histoire finalement est là aussi pour
rappeler les faits pour faire justice
faire VF de vérité pour la mémoire c'est
très affectif aujourd'hui on prend nos
relations sur le maghreb sur le mode de
la mémoire mais je pense qu'on s'en
sortira en écrivant l'histoire et
d'ailleurs elle est largement écrite
heureusement déjà on essaye d'y
contribuer mais je pense que c'est ça
qui permettra d'avoir à l'avenir des des
relations saines parce que tant qu'on
est dans le contentieux dans la fictif
dans le revanchard dans le la tension
liée à tout à toutes les pulsions et les
passions humaines ben on est dans un
dans une logique d'affrontement
l'histoire à mon avis est un facteur de
paix et de pacification est-ce que en
Afrique c'est une grosse question à mon
avis est-ce que les États se vivent
comme des nations
certains il y a des il y a des très
vieilles nations la Tunisie le Maroc
l'Éthiopie l'Egypte dans ces pays très
anciens il y a pas vraiment de problème
dans un certain nombre d'autres qui ont
une histoire très forte aussi au 20e
siècle que ce soit géré ou le Sénégal je
pense que il y a pas de problème non
plus il y en a d'autres il y a 50
en revanche on voit bien pour prendre le
cas de la Libye qui n'est pas très
éloigné que la question de l'État
ne fait pas la nation bon alors ça vient
de loin puisque les Kadhafi et c'est
prédécesseurs n'ont jamais construit une
nation donc elle n'existe pas donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle les états failli il y
en a d'autres notamment au Sahel le
Soudan a éclaté il y a quelques années
on voit bien aussi qu'il y a des états
de la bande sahélienne qui sont
extrêmement fragiles donc si vous voulez
il y a deux processus différents il y a
l'état qui est parfois quasiment disparu
aujourd'hui en lib je sais pas s'il y a
deux états où les sirenaïques et la
Tripolitaine oui et puis dans le Sud qui
est à moitié autonome ça fait trois
et puis la question de la Nation pour
qu'il y a une nation il faut qu'il y ait
une aventure collective durable dont on
est la mémoire l'histoire qui a été
écrit enseigné les nations ça se forge
alors quand ça dure depuis plus de 3000
ans comme la Chine c'est facile quand
c'est très récent et que on n'a pas mis
les outils et que l'État est très faible
et ne peut pas inculquer cette histoire
ben la nation n'existe pas et je crois
que l'Afrique est partagée entre les
deux et parce que souvent on entend
notamment les Africains qui disent bon
il y a cette conférence de Berlin cette
conférence de Berlin c'est une
conférence qui a eu lieu à la fin du 19e
siècle en 1885 à la demande de Bismarck
et les européens se sont partagés
l'Afrique et ils disent bon bah voilà
bah les Européens ont fait des
frontières tout à fait artificielles il
y a une partie de vérité quand même
là-dedans oui bien sûr quand on voit ses
frontières aux cordo il y a pas eu de
recherche de cohérence
à l'intérieur même de l'ensemble par
exemple colonial français on aurait pu
imaginer qu'il y ait des rassemblements
qui soient faits sur des bases
par exemple liés à l'environnement à la
nature au relief au Mali non ça a été
généralement fait sur d'autres bases
autour d'une capitale on a tiré un
cercle administratif quoi très
administratif très militaire très
bureaucratique et le principe fondateur
de l'ohua à l'indépendance de l'Afrique
ça a été en notion d'unité africaine
voilà devenu Union africaine c'est on ne
touche pas aux frontières parce que
sinon on rentre dans une gare sans fin
c'est un principe qu'on peut entendre
sauf que depuis certaines frontières ont
bougé parler du Soudan
Soudan du Sud Soudan du Nord absolument
l'Érythrée aussi avec le a été
impressionnant qui est sorti l'Éthiopie
donc ça veut dire que le principe est
plus fragile qui n'y paraissait ça reste
quand même un principe auquel un certain
nombre d'États sont extrêmement attachés
mais évidemment ça ne correspond pas
vraiment à des réalités culturel voire
religieuse voire ethniques d'où le fait
que seuls l'État peut éventuellement
construire une nation que ce soit par la
guerre ou par le football mais c'est pas
toujours facile alors on oppose souvent
les colonisations les unes avec les
autres sans parler de sans remonter à la
colonisation arabe mais la colonisation
britannique et la colonisation française
par exemple il y a de réelles
différences dans ces colonisations une
colonisation qui est plutôt entre
guillemets civilisatrice chez les
Français elle est beaucoup plus
commerciale chez les Britanniques non on
peut le dire comme ça on peut le dire
comme ça
encore que regarder la puissance de de
la langue anglaise dans les anciens
colonies anglaises très forte elle est
très forte
elle est pas contestée comme la
francophonie aujourd'hui donc on se
demande qui a assimilé en fait
l'assimilation à la française c'est une
assimilation de certains territoires
notamment de l'Algérie des communes du
Sénégal c'était pas une assimilation à
la culture des peuples puisque en en
gros l'école a été distribué avec une
extrême parcimonie c'était
l'assimilation d'une partie des élites
pour le reste le mode de gouvernement
était et il a été inventé en Algérie 19e
siècle il était exactement
identique à ce que les Anglais appellent
l'index Trull c'est à dire on va
gouverner un pays avec très peu de
moyens humains
matériels par le biais des élites
traditionnels avec lesquels on s'entend
on s'entend avec elle soit après la
guerre soit par la négociation
immédiatement avec un échange de bons
procédés des terres des impôts des
femmes des fonctions des médailles etc
et donc cette base là si vous voulez n'a
pas préparé les peuples de la région à
une véritable forme d'assimilation enfin
en tout cas d'aculturation c'est par la
suite c'est c'est les gouvernements
indépendants qui ont créé l'école à la
française et qui ont diffusé la
francophonie en Afrique c'est pas
vraiment la colonisation tout ce qu'on
peut lire et dire compris au Maroc en
Algérie vous vous êtes en train de
remettre en question ce que
les préjugés qui circulent quoi oui
parce qu'on dit on a appris aux
Africains nos ancêtres les Gaulois mais
il y a 2 % des africains qui ont entendu
ça
jamais aller à l'école donc ils n'ont
pas entendu ça donc ce sont les
gouvernements aux indépendants qui eux
ont été séduits par le modèle il voulait
simplement diriger le modèle au lieu de
laisser aux mains des Français qui
étaient d'ailleurs très peu nombreux ils
ont l'indépendance finalement leur a
confié le pouvoir et la première chose
qui a été faite dans la quasi-totalité
des pays ça a été de créer un système
scolaire francophone très proche pour ne
pas dire identiques au système qui avait
été mis en place sous la colonisation
avec bien sûr une africanisation parfois
de l'histoire et de la géographie
et donc oui la francophonie c'est un
phénomène qui est post colonial en
réalité en Afrique
mais on ne le sait plus aujourd'hui
trois générations après tout est oublié
comment vous expliquer que on a
l'impression que comme un Noël ce qui
réunit les anciennes nations les anciens
les anciens colonies britanniques à plus
de corps que justement la Francophonie
qui n'a jamais
eu une place énorme dans les relations
internationales vous savez la France
coloniale elle est passée après
l'Angleterre c'est à dire que ou alors
elle a perdu ses principaux florons au
18e siècle je pense à l'Inde et je pense
à l'Amérique du Nord notamment au Canada
donc elle est passée après elle s'est
appropriée des territoires qui étaient
en fait délaissés par les Britanniques
et qui était des territoires soit sous
peuplés soit très pauvres je pense que
ça aura par exemple ça elle bien sûr il
y avait des peuples il y avait des
civilisations il y avait des villes mais
en réalité c'était des territoires très
pauvres et de surcroît la France a
investi très peu de moyens humains parce
que la colonisation est contemporaine de
la transition démographique en France il
y a jamais eu personne envoyé
donc c'est pas tout à fait l'Histoire
telle qu'on me tire ailleurs sénégalais
absolument et algérien on a l'impression
si vous voulez que tout ça n'est pas su
n'est pas connu on aussi entre une
vision tout à fait irénique
écrite beaucoup par par les Français ou
une vision de remise en question et qui
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs va loin parce
qu'on parle de la wok culture de cette
de cette négation de l'histoire
d'ailleurs on réécrit l'histoire sur la
sur la connaître vraiment oui on en fait
on en fait un programme idéologique un
objet de de lutte idéologique en réalité
c'est grave ça non bah c'est grave du
point de vue de l'histoire et des
historiens parce que la politique et
l'idéologie c'est pas l'histoire c'est
aussi un apprentissage de la haine là
bien sûr mais c'est le rôle de
l'idéologie c'est le rôle aussi de la
politique de mettre en scène de
scénariser des conflits imaginaires on
voit bien que le discours idéologique il
met du sel sur les plaies il raconte des
choses fausses et c'est vrai qu'on est
aux prises aujourd'hui sur l'histoire de
de la colonisation et de l'Afrique à
tout un tas de de mensonges extrêmement
grossiers alors est-ce que les gens les
disent parce qu'ils ne font plus
d'histoires parce qu'ils ne lisent pas
et parce qu'ils s'en tiennent à des
discours caricaturaux ou volontairement
volontairement ou bien est-ce que c'est
de la est-ce que c'est un combat
politique et idéologique ou est-ce que
c'est de l'ignorance quoi qu'il en soit
on gagnerait enseigner ces choses-là et
vous savez qu'en France on a beaucoup de
mal à enseigner cette histoire justement
parce qu'on pense que les polémique
alors que moi je pense qu'elle est pas
si cicatrice il y a quand même un sujet
qui est extrêmement polémique c'est le
face à face franco-algérien qu'on a
beaucoup de mal à aborder de part et
d'autre de la Méditerranée de façon
apaisée quoi c'est c'est c'est infernal
cette histoire
il est devenu infernal elle ne l'était
pas ah bon dans les années 60-70 la
relation était apaisée les Algériens
juste après l'indépendance alors dans
les décennies y compris de la part de
Boumédiène ou médiane n'était pas le
deuxième président algérien après Ben
Bella vous avez gagné la guerre si vous
voulez faut quand même se rendre compte
les gens qui ont gagné la guerre ils
sont ils sont en général assez contents
d'autant plus que cette guerre elle
paraissait au début totalement un
faisable et surtout un gagnable donc au
bout de 8 ans d'une guerre extrêmement
dure 54 62 54 62 elle a été gagnée quand
on regarde les actualités qu'on lit les
discours les textes etc des années 60-70
il y avait la fierté d'avoir gagné cette
égalité qui avait été réclamé si
longtemps aux français puisque les
Français avaient prophété l'égalité sans
la donner et la décolonisation en
Algérie spécialement puisque c'était la
France juridiquement parlant depuis 1848
l'idée c'était d'obtenir l'égalité et la
finalement l'indépendance a offert
l'égalité
[Musique]
d'après-guerre c'est ça le grand
paradoxe mais si on revient à la
colonisation juste avant cette
indépendance de 1962 est-ce que Charles
de Gaulle qui a jamais cru au fait que
la France pouvait coexister avec
l'Algérie qui était pas un protectorat
qui était une colonie avec trois
départements auront Alger au territoire
national Constantine exactement comme si
on était dans le Gers ou l'autre est-ce
que il avait pas raison en général de
Gaulle en disant on va tout faire c'est
un jouable on peut pas on peut pas
coexister on peut pas cohabiter c'est
pas possible au 19e siècle on a fabriqué
un mensonge notamment la Troisième
République elle a dit on assimile on
assimile l'Algérie mais on assimile 500
peuples et ça ça a été payé un seul
urbain c'était un des aspirateurs de
Napoléon III qui lui était pour
exactement ce que vous êtes en train de
dire mais métisse antillais
effectivement conseillé
et de la politique du royaume arabe de
Napoléon III bien sûr mais on a fabriqué
ce mensonge il a fallu un pour en sortir
et de Gaulle qui a décidé d'en sortir
mais le mensonge était total si vous
voulez vous dites d'un côté aux Français
l'Algérie c'est la France c'est comme
l'Auvergne comme vous dites comme le
Gers ou la Bretagne et de l'autre il y a
effectivement il y a une population
française qui est là qui vit dans selon
les lois de la France mais à côté dans
les montagnes dans les Hauts Plateaux
dans les petits coins il y a un peuple
de plusieurs millions de personnes qui
certes son français mais qui sont sujets
français qui n'ont pas la citoyenneté
française qui vont plus ou moins à
l'école et plutôt moins que plus qui
n'ont pas vraiment de secteurs
économiques l'industrialisation de
l'Algérie elle a commencé pendant la
guerre d'Algérie c'est quand même un
problème la scolarisation elle a
commencé après la deuxième guerre
mondiale et il y a eu plus
d'investissements en Algérie pendant la
guerre d'Algérie que pendant toute la
période coloniale parce que au dernier
moment on se dit enfin de Gaulle se dit
avant de partir il faut quand même il
faut donner les moyens de à ce pays de
vivre et de ne pas sombrer dans le
communisme et dans l'hostilité à la
France mais le problème c'est la
troisième République qui a fabriqué ça
donc fabriquer ça et puis les islamistes
se sont arrivés et là l'islamisme c'est
une une espèce d'idéologie qui a
complètement changé la donne et les
rapports entre l'Occident et les pays
arabes
oui il vient de loin il a été inventé en
Égypte à la fin du XIXe siècle dans une
forme plutôt libérale que les Français
ont appelé la Salafia ou la réforme par
comparaison protestant et puis il y a
une radicalisation qui s'est faite à la
fois par les Saoudiens par les Wahab
habite saoudiens et par les Frères
musulmans en Égypte voyez donc tout ça
remonte au début du 20e siècle
et ça maturé ça cuit ça et ça ça confie
dans les dans les sociétés notamment du
d'Afrique du Nord et du Moyen-Orient eux
ils le présentent comme la
décolonisation culturelle c'est-à-dire
les États ont obtenu l'indépendance et
la décolonisation politique et nous on
va pratiquer la décolonisation
culturelle sauf que Sousse c'est comme
ça qu'on a vendu le l'islamisme en
français en disant c'est une reconquête
identitaire sauf que on voit bien en
Algérie la reconquête identitaire
d'abord elle se tourne contre leur
propre dirigeants d'où la guerre civile
algérienne qui a été extrêmement
violente qui a été le premier
contemporain depuis on en a eu en Syrie
on en a eu en Irak on en a eu d'autres
Moyen-Orient on voit bien que là il y a
une tentative de prise du pouvoir par un
islam politique extrêmement intolérant
qui a d'ailleurs qui est pas neuf dans
l'histoire on a eu des précédents
historiques qui est un qui est à la fois
éradicateur
révisionniste et puis surtout qui veut
n'avoir qu'une tête ils ne veulent plus
le refus des minorités toute diversité
refus de toute processus démocratique et
installer directement le règne de Dieu
sur terre c'est ce que Saïd El khodes
peut appeler la hakimiya c'est-à-dire il
y a même pas besoin de gouvernement pas
besoin d’état Dieu gouverne directement
sur Terre les hommes individuellement
etc souvent on voit quand il y a des
élections c'est très rare que les
islamistes et plus d'un tiers des voix
mais finalement ils ont réussi à partir
de ce tiers à renverser un certain
nombre de sociétés et on est dans une
forme d'impasse aujourd'hui alors est-ce
que c'est pas dû au fait qu'il y ait
plus d'hommes forts par exemple Nasser
dans les années 50
qui sort d'un rendez-vous avec avec tes
frères musulmans en Égypte et les Frères
musulmans lui demandent d'imposer le
voile partout enfin dans la société et
c'est pas très bien daté mais je crois
que c'est un peu avant le pouvoir sur
les années au début des années 50 et il
est mort de rire ce que de le dire et en
disant vous savez ce qu'ils m'ont
demandé c'est que vous portiez le voir
et tout et évidemment il refuse il veut
pas du tout alors il y en a serre grand
bonhomme Bourguiba tout ça c'était quand
même des gens qui étaient des
nationalistes
très opposés à la colonisation mais qui
était pas du tout dans la religion si
vous laissez grande figures du milieu du
20e siècle ils sont ils ont eu leur
popularité parce qu'ils ont obtenu
l'indépendance
parce qu'ils ont eu un discours
modernisateur parce qu'ils ont voulu
créer des nations modernes promettent
l'école le développement
à tous et le problème c'est que ils ont
entraîné derrière leur peuple avec même
une passion incroyable dans le cas de
Nasser le problème c'est que les
promesses du régime nacerien n'ont pas
été tenues il avait les moyens de
développer l'Egypte mais il voulait
faire la guerre il a fait la guerre en
au Yémen il a fait la guerre à Israël
bon il l'a subi puis il en a fait une
seconde même si c'est sa date qui était
là à ce moment-là
l'Egypte s'est construit comme un
appareil militaire c'était la grande
faiblesse de ces pays alors Bourguiba
elle n'a pas sombré lui dans le
militarisme parce qu'au contraire il
s'en méfier mais finalement c'était le
pays le plus pauvre de la région qui
n'avait pas vraiment de ressources et
lui aussi n'a pas eu les moyens de faire
cette politique même si il a empêché
l'explosion démographique comme en
Égypte voir comment en Algérie donc
voilà c'est c'est c'est cette
malheureuse situation finalement de
l'échec du ce qu'on appelle le
développementalisme l'Union soviétique
les États-Unis les Occidentaux tout le
monde voulait le développement
l'étirementiste aussi et le
développement n'a pas eu lieu et du coup
ça a créé une situation une impasse et
aujourd'hui on est dans cette et on est
dans cet impact on en sortira parce
qu'il y a quand même beaucoup
d'intellectuels dans la région en
Tunisie en Egypte qui se battent au
Maroc aussi qui en Algérie qui font un
travail pareil tout à fait remarquable
de clarification idéologique religieuses
politiques qui font le bilan du XXe
siècle finalement le problème c'est que
il y a une temporalité décalée entre les
masses entre ce qu'enseigne l'école et
ce que pense à certains nombre de
penseurs peut-être malheureusement il va
avoir du temps pour que ces idées
règnent ou en tout cas mouvement Irak en
Algérie bah finalement il a débouché sur
une impasse c'est toujours le FLN qui
est au pouvoir oui mais vous voyez c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé avec les
printemps arabes en 2011 ça s'est passé
en Algérie plus récemment on voit que
l'aspiration des peuples là existe elle
existe l'aspiration la liberté à la
dignité à l'égalité au travail mais
évidemment
on est quand même dans une période très
difficile et la gravation de la
situation économique internationale
n'est pas pour rien dans le dans le dans
le finalement le fait que ces
difficultés sont entretenues j'ai une
question à vous poser si vous aviez un
livre de littérature africaine à
recommander ça serait lequel
je pense à la saga de mulot de mammery
l'Opium et le bâton et d'autres qui sont
la colline oubliée qui sont remarquables
parce que ils écrivent l'histoire de des
Algériens ils écrivent aussi notre
histoire d'accord et c'est très bien
écrit
c'est pas traduit puisqu'il écrit
directement en français souvent un
avantage et il a un très beau style et
surtout bon voilà c'est de la grande
littérature alors lisez Mouloud mémory
merci Pierre Verne merci à vous
[Musique]